ciao ragazzi bentornati all'ultima
puntata di questa stagione di vita
buttata il tema di oggi è odio come il
tema di oggi
it it
non è bello comunque i ragazzi ho
scritto una canzone ho scritto una
canzone
mammamia bravissima questo 5 altissimo
sia stato a tenere iniziato già nota per
finire in bellezza ho pensato di
cambiare un pochino le regole di vita
buttata che è stato deciso di infilare
all'interno del format un po di
creatività e ho chiesto di farmi sapere
degli aneddoti di vita vissuta delle
storie però utilizzando la musica dal
momento che io e la musica siamo a fini
quanto un t rex è un gambo di sedano ho
pensato di avere ospite una ragazza
un'amica che io stimo tantissimo dal
punto di vista umano ma soprattutto da
quello professionale stiamo parlando di
una cantautrice che ha scritto brani che
molto probabilmente avete sentito ogni
giorno vedi metto qua sotto
sto parlando di federica abate buon
ragazzi buongiorno come va a un p mib il
incerti si emoziona tantissimo alla
sappi che tu porti il talento e la
conoscenza della materia
ti chiedo di essere buona so che tu sei
una persona buona ma credo che ci
potremmo arrivare tanto
ok troviamo la canzoni che ho dedicato
alla mia ex
[Musica]
guarda invece ai maledetta bella però
non c'era un insulto pesante che mi
aspettavo che inizia e ci stava comunque
ai rimpiangerai inizia ad avere paura
non pensavo che partissimo così camuffa
la voce brough quindi saper ascoltare un
brano che ti invito a immaginare un po
tratto
no non è trap
[Musica]
solo
c'è chi a stento celesti
[Musica]
non volevo dirti nobile
nato ha preso schiaffi porca miseria
chiave fortuna sono sceso dal bus spaccò
il parabrezza è stato decisa e che posso
cantare faccio schifo non avrete trova
al carcere stiamo andato questo è giusto
anzi ti ringraziamo e conosci dal
carcere parentesi segreti i capelli di
fede che volano e perché abbiamo sparato
addosso un ventilatore e non perché sto
facendo meno fare agli auto steve un
video di beyoncé ogni tanto vuoi
muoverti cia puglia motivio la nostra
canzone racconta la strana avventura di
una mia amica a 20 era lei si trovava
una festa distesa su un prato con un
ragazzo quando nel bel mezzo del
romantico momento questa mia amica
percepisce del calore sul suo petto
inizio gli era stava facendo addosso
bovidi l'arte tra prato questa sera
nello baggio non ci ha dato un po
sbagliato questo pesce che si muove
gratinati sono trono di spagna sulla
faccia di ragazzo scappa droghe in alto
non le stelle ma un'ombra che discende
significa sopra le tette giallo che
sgorga
a dirlo stavolta amia fissato sul tetto
scambiato preparato bagnando voglio
pisciare sul tema
intanto le gocce scaldato si finisce no
hanno questa canzone l'ho scritta io
esatto diciamolo questa versione molto
meglio si sta spogliando questa cosa c'è
quindi volta tv su questo è quello a
corto di sapone per aumentare lo share
sembra bianca e la coscia impurità e
tutti quanti mi dicono ma al mare ci vai
mai ricordo dirti io lavoro perche non
mi
[Musica]
ma i tuoi proprio bravissima questa la
preferita fino ad adesso tra ist e lo
abbiamo preferito di questa ragazza si
monica bravissimo non diciamo mai nomi
per un pò di privacy
hai ragione vive presso viene da hanno
studiato prezzo
[Musica]
non c'è bisogno
anche questa è la planeta del cipresso
cesso molto bello anche il momento in
cui le perderà si perde questa è la vera
cioè o della pasta abbiamo
[Musica]
perché non basta
non vogliamo la vasta sottili
ramona pasto tutti di la morte il rigo
vision voi alla vostra colazione perché
la pasta tutti
tutto inedite rigatoni la pasta liscia
[ __ ] vogliamo la pasta giusto basta
tutto il di pigato né da e poi la pasta
ma come fare scusa mi succede fatta in
cina canzoni della sua mano così a
tavolo samone cure
[Musica]
però questa ci sta che avesse già fatta
basta
5 bene mangia a colazione la pasta tutto
il di tutto il sì sul timo
[Musica]
ma vorrei che non bene
l'ultima luce all'ultima cambiavamo
veramente mondo
[Musica]
ma bossi ma faccio
come fare
ma come è possibile che sia successo
[Musica]
ma scusa ma tu sappi che tornerai che
faremo un format sono così tutto il dio
[Musica]
buongiorno notte comunque ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla fine di questa puntata
sembra in realtà alla fine di questa
proprio stagione di vita buttate sono
contentissimo di averlo fatto contro i
ragazzi davvero c'è sì ma tutti e due
ho paura di questo abbraccio in realtà
dopo che ho visto quello di cui sei
capace o timore se avete voglia di far
di contaminare da questo da questa roba
da questo virus
pitecus di lasko i link qua sotto avrete
la possibilità di seguire i tuoi
instagram ti metto anche i pezzi tipo di
tutti un video musicale così almeno
arrivato un pochino di scoperta grazie
mille fede davvero anni dove ragazzi che
dire questo qui ovviamente non è un
addio ma siamo arrivati alla fine
veramente di questa stagione di vita
buttata riprenderemo da settembre con
nuove idee
gli stessi ospiti e nuovi questa
settimana partiamo per il william perché
non sapesse ho fatto un milione di
iscritti su youtube
ho pensato insieme a tutto il wimu stima
di andare a casa della gente bussare
citofonare e ringraziarvi dal vivo
quindi faremo una settimana di tour per
tutta l'italia andando a casa di persone
che non sanno che stiamo arrivando se
volete più o meno sapere in che località
siamo cosa stiamo facendo in che modo ci
sta muovendo seguiteci o sui nostri
instagram oppure comunque a settembre
credo che uscirà fuori un video nel
quale racconteremo tutta quanta questa
storia io vi invito sempre iscrivervi a
questo canale attivare da campanella
delle notifiche purtroppo per la prima
volta non vi davano appuntamento alla
prossima settimana ma sappiate che
comunque durante quest'estate usciremo
con dei video e delle cose nuove un
pochino per sperimentare fino ad allora
divertitevi prendeteli se potete una
vacanza lavorate altrimenti un po come
farò io anche se cercano in tutti i modi
di rilassarmi vi mando un bacio grande
alla prossima ciao
questo è sugo
[Musica]